I want to talk about your movie family
one of the things that's really sweet
it's it's a sweet story of your
relationship with a nice yes and she's
not that popular and she's awkward and
she's been through a tough face and
you're being trying to be really nice to
her and get her out of a show and she
one of the things that's sort of the
backdrop of the movie is she becomes
enamored with the band a real-life band
yes
insane clown posse same calm Posse yeah
and do you know about anything yeah
you've been around a while yeah somebody
really knows that yeah might be asthma
you faked my person I've known this for
well they have a rabid fan base yes very
very loyal the Jerry loves yes I mean it
was really incredible the whole Juggalo
community knew we were making this
little movie and I they brought
themselves from all over the country
people came to kind of participate in
the movie and set up shop so we could
shoot this festival called The Gathering
right and I have never heard I don't
know if I've ever felt more loved up by
a group of people they were so
supportive their whole thing is positive
energy yes yes absolutely and you know
no one's on the outside there's no we're
not marginalizing anyone and we're kind
of D authorizing the other and I think
it's there it's such a beautiful message
for everyone right now
I mean they're an intense crowd but
they're it's beautiful we have a clip
anything I believe this is where you're
helping your knee so you're trying to
encourage your knees to upper game a
little bit in terms of maybe makeup yeah
I don't know what she's doing but that's
yeah like self-care yeah yeah giving her
a makeover all right let's try to give
you a clip from family take a look
do you want to make over nothing's what
do you mean no thanks just no thanks I'm
not interested you're gonna get a
makeover no please
it'll be fun self-tanner I don't need to
be cameraman end-organ we're gonna
change that don't hit it don't eat it
I'm just gonna clean up I'm gonna clean
up a few stragglers I'm shutting it down
Oh
no no that's the order
family family is in select theaters this
friday and taylor schilling thanks so
much for being here
[Applause]